[Music]
as I'm taping this right now there is a
massive wildfire burning about 70 miles
north of here in Ventura County as of
just a couple minutes ago it had already
burned over 50 thousand acres and over
30,000 homes have been evacuated I'm
sure by the time you see this those
numbers are gonna go up significantly
here in Los Angeles there sit flying
around all over the place and there's a
dark gray haze and deep smell of smoke I
just walked my dog for literally two
minutes two minutes and not only
couldn't I see all the way down to the
end of the block because of the smoke
but my clothes absolutely stink right
now we just finished up our interview
for this week with Jessica Flanagan from
the University of Richmond and although
we never edit for content on this show
we actually are probably going to edit
out a couple coughs and hacks as the air
quality in the studio is pretty bad
right now ironically our interview had a
lot to do with Public Health so stay
tuned and for that I don't mention any
of this for pity for me dealing with
some soot and some smoke today as much
as how things can be put into
perspective pretty quickly of course a
quick perusal of Twitter allowed me to
see people saying California's burning
because of its leftist sins and others
saying it's burning because of global
warming and lack of regulation yes even
natural disasters are political these
days as we're in the midst of the
holiday season perhaps let's try to be a
little less political as we run out 2017
the spirit of the season is about joy
and giving not fighting and bickering
yet unfortunately it seems we do the
latter two a lot more often than the
four more to these days the people being
affected far worse than me by these
fires are on the left and on the right
they're pro-choice and they're pro-life
they're black and they're white and
they're Christian and they're atheist
it's not just good ideas that can bring
us together but also bad events so let's
not make them worse with an extra
helping of hate I'm gonna try to be a
little less partisan a little more open
and a little less political as the year
comes to an end I think I do a pretty
decent job of being fair and open-minded
in general but a touch more of those
traits never hurt especially around
holiday time politics is important but
it isn't warm
port and then finding some room in your
life to be grateful to be decent and to
be tolerant my challenge if you're up
for it is to perhaps try being a little
more tolerant yourself in the spirit of
the season I know that your intellectual
opponents and sometimes even friends and
family members often won't make it easy
but I think it'll be worth the effort as
we wind down this crazy year whether we
like it or not we're in this thing
together and perhaps putting out some
brush fires now will spare us from some
major fires in the future
[Music]
you